all right let's let's get into the what
I think the people want to hear yeah
what do they want to hear our thoughts
on Russell Peters new comedy special or
no no no okay okay we'll stop moving
around
so Russell Brand's new comedy special
just who are the famous Russ's that's it
I think you just Russell Russell Peter
do that's yeah okay we'll talk about
Russ first Adam 22 yeah and the whole I
mean a lot of the same points have been
made already I don't know what you could
really say other than it's corny it's
just funny yeah it's just funny like the
whole they would describe the situation
so Russ got on last episode we're
talking about Russ getting on power 105
and yeah Breakfast Club bragging about
like you know that you know what time it
is they know what time it is we got
footage this and that better that it uh
and basically he paid some dudes to jump
smoke perp
and they they hit him pretty good they
[ __ ] him up and then he and then uh he
blows it Adam pretty much calls him out
on Twitter mm-hmm and is like you hired
three people to come [ __ ] me up and I
guess like they sucker-punched him and
they just ran away yeah which is even
funnier mm-hmm I wonder if they pulled
up and they're like oh he's a lot bigger
than we thought they just punched him
and took off running like and then they
called Russ like yeah we did it
and he was getting his nails done to was
[ __ ] anyway I'm fine I mean hey I get
[ __ ] manicures all the time I'm saying
it's like it's a bizarre like like it's
a very vulnerable place to be like I
just got out of a manicure yeah and
that's when you get run up oh yeah I
know you got your hands just got clean
now you gotta throw them and get them
dirty would have been really funny if
like Russell
ran up and then Adam just like knocked
all three of them out then he walked
back in he's just like got another one
yeah or if he just like held of his
fingernails is that kill stop oh damn we
have eyes you like Jess got him done we
could reschedule the face yeah I know
what is that uh is that gloss finish
yeah bro it's nice isn't I don't want to
[ __ ] that up for you though we'll come
back next week come back next week gel
manicure yeah it's [ __ ] Adam people
like calls him out on Twitter yeah and
then Russ just they had like a back and
forth back and forth like an hour
spirited back and forth that's pretty
great I'm pretty [ __ ] great to read
that it was great to read how much of an
idiot Russ is yeah and then he goes
bosses don't get their hands dirty
bosses don't get that Nami u55 yeah
that's it yeah it's not the bosses don't
get their hands dirty
you can't fight anyone that's not in
high school yeah yeah it's like me and
Cody yeah anyone five eight and under
actually that's not true
I'm not picking no fights with anyone
yeah yeah I've never fought and there's
a good reason it's not because I'm a
boss I don't get my hands dirty that's
cuz it's partly because of that but it's
also partly because I couldn't do it
physically I mean I would just get my
ass handed to me I love is like the
classic like little man in the squad in
high school I always got [ __ ] with cuz
I was the smallest one huh so I learned
pretty quick like not to open my mouth
all the time I used to talk a lot of
[ __ ] and then like when someone either
got done fighting or just got their ass
whooped but they're still bigger than me
like with [ __ ] you talking about a
little man in my house I was just you
you put in a good try man that was a
good pop Paul please please please
please [ __ ] him up please please [ __ ]
move again please please I'm gonna yeah
so that's what happened I almost got
jumped by these eight Mexican dudes yeah
I think you told the story before yeah
cuz two of them got their asses beat by
doing my friend yeah they would
just had it with losing yeah they were
like alright we can't go through all
right we're gonna get all eight of us go
for the small they're gonna get he had
the bus stop alone dummy we're gonna get
him right now and they still didn't do
anything almost guys they all pulled up
and you're like I got that almost got
ganked homie like hair and they're like
oh yeah for sure yeah for sure
oh yeah no problem yeah I'm just gonna
help it my fingers oh thank you come on
guys come on oh sorry me give me one
reason why we shouldn't [ __ ] you up
right now I got some some homework some
mother should I gotta so I'm gonna oh oh
yeah yeah cool not even given a reason I
kind of listen I would love to I got
some but I got some awesome [ __ ] you
know how it is
right it's like it got some stuff oh
yeah yeah no oh yeah yeah we got some
stuff next time for sure next time you
know the economy that got me was like
rust does everything by himself but
fight yeah that was yeah it's like I
just I hate I hate that he is selling
like he's hitting streaming numbers
getting paid off Spotify just to hire
people to beat other people up that
think he's whack that's so lame I know
that is the a direct contradiction of
all his like when him haters like when
they talk about you I love it I love it
you know you don't yeah it's under your
skin you [ __ ] stop lying
yeah I'm not lying you're not I just
love the fact that he actually responded
because at that point you lost yeah yeah
like the hour long back and forth on
Twitter it's like it's like you lost
yeah well yeah they got to a point where
you were like ass it off and it's like
okay yeah so all this [ __ ] you were
saying is not
and like don't ever cut don't I never
ever want to hear rust get on a record
talking about I love these haters no
they drive you crazy they drive you so
crazy that you got to hire people to
beat them up it's funny cuz it's like
all he has to talk about yeah like his
songs are just all they're all about
that or it's like a like it was like
that and like women yeah we're the -
yeah things I wasn't like the first five
six on this house the rough guys who
can't fight and the girls in high school
18 year old girls I know that was a
funny part he was saying Adams only fans
are little boys and it's like mmm yeah
but yours are little girls yeah
now what are you it's only ever like
girls with like hopeless romantic in
like Old English yeah and their profile
yeah that like Russ yeah those are all
the ones to like I don't get all the
rust hate I know their whole profile
Russell
where's misunderstood and do who who
think think doing their homework is
being on their grand does arrest fans am
on my grind homie hitting the gym
hitting the gym yeah I'm on my grind
getting that good Fitness in you know
hitting the gym once a day grind
grinding dude Ryan damn [ __ ] grinding
now you know what grinding in the gym is
[ __ ] 680 put yep being in that [ __ ]
eight hours a day that's grinding Mark
Wahlberg three days that's grinding this
awesome clothes Dustin
[Music]
these are custom clown
these are gusting ho
[Music]